hi everyone and welcome to our facebook
live my name is val
and i work for the science media office
team and today i will be your host for
the next 45 minutes
during this time we will explore a
concerning global trend
where the international community
support for democracy is declining
influencing democratic backsliding
worldwide
slipping closer to despotism as
democratic ideas
fade so that's why i want to introduce
you today to
susan hyde and she's joining us from the
university of california at berkeley
and she is an expert as an international
election observation
election fraud international norms and
democracy promotion
and susan will help us unpack her recent
review published in science
and the ideas it presents so before i
pass them back to suzanne i want to
encourage the audience to leave any
comments or questions
that you have for us so we can ask those
during our discussion
so back to you susan welcome thank you
val thanks for the
invitation to be here i am really happy
to be here to talk about this essay
i want to just briefly say what it's
about um
the angle that i wanted to pursue was a
focus on
international relations and how changes
at the global level
in geopolitics but also in global trends
in support or the lack of support for
democracy
are influencing this trend that's been
documented by a lot of other scholars
who are focused on comparative politics
which we call democratic backsliding and
democratic backsliding is basically the
movement
away from democratic institutions
in countries that have had them the
movements away from democracy can be
very gradual
they can be very subtle they can be hard
to document
they ultimately move a country though
closer to authoritarianism and they can
include really abrupt shifts to
authoritarianism
but um one of the things that i want to
emphasize
is that this is something that can
happen to countries that are only
partially democratic
and it can also as we've been seen
happen to countries that have been
functioning democracies for quite some
time
so the essay i start to use it as an
excuse to
to engage in some discussion of the
consequences we think
there are likely to be of this global
turn away from
international support for democracy
which i think has been
pressuring leaders around the world to
look and act more democratic than they
might otherwise have been inclined to be
has provided direct support for citizen
movements
around the world and has also engaged in
some
democracy assistance programs that have
helped a lot of countries
develop democratic institutions many of
those things are around um but they've
they've in some ways lessened um and
other forms of public support for
democracy have also
declined um which is something that i
think is affecting this broader trend of
democratic backsliding in interesting
ways
yeah so thank you susan and one of the
things that you're saying
is that uh the international support for
democracy provides a direct support for
citizens but for example
in the case of venezuela but they're
trying to call for free and fair
elections
and basically to order to get to do that
they need to create a new institution
but there is a divide in the
international community so how can
citizens gain the international
community support
for democrat movements yeah it's a
really tough problem one of the things
that i
um mention in my in this review and that
i've thought a lot about more generally
in my work
is that when people are critical of
democracy assistance and democracy
promotion
i think that they're sometimes comparing
it to the world in which international
actors
wouldn't interfere at all that they
would stay out of the domestic political
business
of sovereign states throughout the world
historically we have seen that that's
rarely the case
if countries are not engaged in
supporting democratic institutions
they're often engaged in
doing other things in that country some
of which are more partisan in nature
may involve foreign election
interference may involve direct support
for candidates that they think will
pursue
policies that are that are closer to
their goals so you brought up the case
of venezuela
i think it's a really um tough
situation in in a lot of ways um
and it highlights in some ways the value
of having
outside support for democracy that is
nonpartisan in nature and that can be
focused on developing the democratic
institutions
what's not clear is how to get the
international community to
better support venezuelan
re-democratization we might call it
and and many of the problems that
venezuela is currently experiencing
i think are exacerbated by the
governance issues that
are are really closely tied to this
trend that i'm discussing in the essay
of democratic backsliding
well then let's hope that in the
meantime as they raise their voices the
international community continue to hear
that conversation which brings me to the
next point because now with covet
i'm concerned that certain governments
might use that
as an excuse to push certain elections
so
could that even happen can elections go
away like
absolutely completely gone this is a
trend that's being followed very closely
by a number of international actors i
think the
the organization that is following it
most publicly and most clearly is ifis
the international foundation for
electoral systems
they've posted a tracker of
uh countries that have chosen to
postpone their elections
most of them for reasons related to
covid19
some of them have been national
elections and some of them have
even been presidential elections i am
concerned that this is a really handy
excuse for some types of leaders around
the world
who may use the excuse the sort of
legitimate public health excuse
of uh covet 19 and of of the global
pandemic
to to postpone elections for public
health reasons
um and then not be any great hurry to
bring them back
so far as i show in the essay we really
haven't seen
a sharp trend away from countries
holding elections
almost all countries in the world as i
document are now holding
direct elections for national office
many of them are
already pretty fraudulent but what we
haven't yet seen and what we might see
possibly related to this is
a trend i'm going to be following very
closely are we going to actually have
countries stop holding elections
entirely
so far i don't think that that's
happened yet but i think it's entirely
within the range of possibility and i'll
be paying close to 10.
well let's just hope that that doesn't
happen i agree i think it's important to
really take care of a democratic process
so can you talk a little bit about
what is a fragile fraudulent election
what does that entail
yeah there's a point actually related to
the prior question that's very much tied
to the question of what's a fraudulent
election so i mentioned that most
countries
in the world are holding
elections for national office with
direct voting
there's only a small handful of
countries that haven't held those
elections in the past decade
and what is really important to
emphasize when i talk about this trend
is that
many of those elections are fraudulent
many of those elections are rigged many
of those elections are stacked
um in favor not just in favor of the
incumbent but set up such that the
incumbent cannot lose those elections
and so fraudulent elections can be
manipulated
well in advance of election day they can
be manipulated on election day
and i also consider it to be election
fraud when
an incumbent or or an election occurs
um the result is not what a set of
powerful political actors wanted
and so they simply fail to acknowledge
the election results or nullify the
election results if they're if they're
not consistent with what they
what they wanted those are all forms of
election manipulation um that
i could talk about types of election
fraud all day there's many
many types of election fraud many ways
to rig elections
um and historically leaders have been
quite creative
well that is actually concerning is that
why then you were interested to be an
international election observation do
you have to know about all these types
in europe
uh so international election observers
at least those that are
from reputable organizations and that
are affiliated with those types of
missions
have a few different types of expertise
so sometimes they have very deep
expertise in the country
sometimes they're combined with people
who have deep expertise about
elections around the world maybe don't
have the same level of country expertise
um and in in on an individual team those
those types of people are often paired
up
um to uh share their expertise both
about the
the country and the culture on the
language
as well as the political history with
with individuals
like me who are sort of generalists
about
technologies of of election
administration
election manipulation and problems that
we might see um
throughout the world process so is that
why you went to venezuela in 2004
as an observer since you had that
journalist technology background
yeah so at the time it was um uh i was
still a phd student so i
one could say i was still developing my
expertise but i had the opportunity to
go and to begin to learn more about that
and i was there for part of with the
carter center for
um one of the recall signature
reverification processes that ugo chavez
initiated in order to try to stay in
power
even after there was a pretty large
citizen movement against him so
you know i learned a lot through that
process i think chavez was one of these
leaders who was relatively good at
um maintaining the plausible deniability
that he
was not doing something so far out of
line that
um that it was really clear that the
international community had to come in
strong and
and condemn what he was doing um and and
in that way he was sort of
very good at manipulating the process to
his to his own advantage
um using more subtle forms of election
manipulation technology
some of which are are um
not necessarily illegal um but we think
as scholars of democracy things that are
not necessarily associated with
uh the ideal type of democratic election
that we can imagine
yeah so these so we have an election
process in place
and it seems like the framework is just
continues to be outdated
is it that these frameworks cannot catch
up
to modern days so that
governments that want to go more towards
authoritarianism doesn't take advantage
of this
it's very hard to design a process
that's completely
bomb-proof right a lot there's a wide
variation in electoral systems there's
wide variation in systems of election
administration
we think some of them are a bit more
robust than others um some
seem to just be more resilient to
challenges although you know as we see
more challenges around the world i
suspect
we'll learn more about um more about
that
one of the things that i think is
important to emphasize though
is that um there's really three
important things to keep your eye on
one is what the leader is doing one is
what the in
the existing institutions incentivize
and one is what the citizens and the
political parties are doing so those
three things
i think are really important to continue
to pay attention to for any country that
you're interested in
in watching um in terms of these trends
and i i think venezuela
you know i know that you're from
venezuela and and uh man
is really a polarized political
situation and when politics
are so polarized it can be very hard for
citizens to
have faith in the institutions um and
have faith in the leaders who are
occupying those
institutions in those positions of power
because they have seen
their own position and their own ability
to exercise their rights be threatened
so much it becomes very hard for
citizens to
um to trust the process and so one of
the things that i emphasize in the piece
is just that
as we see a decline in international
support for democracy around the world
um one of the one of the open questions
is really
um uh the degree to which citizen
movements
in favor of democracy um will be able to
overcome the authoritarian tendencies of
governments that that attempt
to their countries uh for further in the
direction of authoritarianism
yeah i hope that you know the venezuelan
people and any other country that wants
to continue these democratic movements
can continue to work towards that as the
international community
continues to listen i also want to
remind the audience that they can leave
any questions
down below so we can ask professor susan
and i see as well that we have people
connecting from bangladesh cameroon
india pakistan and even the u.s so thank
you so much for
for joining us i see that many people
are interested in the state of democracy
i have a question here from dude masking
math and the question is would
post-cover 19 elections and countries
having hard time in economics and
pandemics have any potential to change
the context within
yeah so i think um what we're seeing
right now is a really complex set
of what some might call um
uh emergencies uh that governments are
dealing with and the concern
is that some more authoritarian
governments
or some leaders who are interested in
making their own
institutions more authoritarian are
trying to push in that direction
will take advantage of these crises
to consolidate their hold on power
but there there are a couple of
countervailing forces which i think
maybe
is partly related to this question one
of the
countervailing forces is just that when
there are
economic crises uh the the government
and the parties in power tend to
to feel tend to be less popular and
um if they're simultaneously moving in
an authoritarian direction that can
create
some uh added incentives for citizens to
protest
against um against the government as as
other scholars have documented in
in historical the combination with a
pandemic is something we haven't
seen on this scale before so there's not
a lot of history to go on
um in terms of how widespread elections
currently are
and how many countries are having major
public health crises associated with the
global pandemic
as well as the economic consequences of
that
so you know i don't know how it's going
to play out it's the short answer
but i do think what i would be paying
attention to is how um governments in
power are trying to
uh use this as a as an excuse to
consolidate that power yeah well i'll
look forward to your comments
later on i'm gonna have to send you an
email because i would love to have your
insights as this continues to develop
i have another question here from megan
phelan and she asked can you talk a
little bit about how
long democratic backsliding has been
happening in the u.s
how much of that time have scholars been
studying it as it impacts the us
[Music]
yeah so i'll say first that i'm not an
expert in american politics i have a lot
of colleagues around the hallway that
i'm currently sitting in who focus on on
american politics but many of them have
not focused on democratic backsliding at
all in their career
so suddenly i'm having a lot more
conversations with my colleagues in
american politics and
you know who focus their research on on
u.s politics about this topic
um i would say that a number of people
have been focused on
threats and inequalities in american
democracy for a very long time
so there's a lot of ways in which u.s
democracy has been
fundamentally flawed one might say at
least for the experiences of some types
of voters
um the the efforts to disenfranchise
often poor often african-american
individuals has
been really extensive and that that
history is long and i don't want to
discount that
there's something else happening now as
well
which is that at least
for the past several years
there have been growing forces within
the republican party especially that
seem anti-democratic and that are
connected to
anti-democracy subcomponents of
political parties in other countries
around the world
um so this is not just i'm not pointing
to the republican party specifically
i'm saying that this is something that's
happening in a lot of political parties
around the world
um and it's unique in a lot of ways for
uh as we've been watching the the
current u.s president to be the one
who's
um most directly talking about um and
trying to initiate threats to democracy
uh so that's that i've that i've seen um
how long has it been
going on um that people have been paying
attention to this in the us
if you count um you know the
inequalities in u.s democracy people
have been paying attention to that issue
for quite some time
if you're just talking about what's been
happening in the in the past several
years
um uh people talk about for example
um packing the courts as a sign of
democratic erosion that's something that
happened in
hungary and poland for example um and so
trying to introduce partisan bias
and to erode uh the impartiality of the
judiciary that's something
i think we can trace that trend back uh
part of that question is actually being
related now to a second question from
iran and he's asking is the u.s going to
have
international elections observance and
if so how many and how are they going to
choose
which states to monitor yeah that's a
really
tricky question so we have had
international observers in the u.s
from the organization from security and
cooperation in europe
for democratic institutions and human
rights the osce oh dear we've had them
here since 2002
and in 2016 we had also a delegation
from the organization of american states
um this year uh the
osceodia that's been that the us is
obligated to invite
um did a needs assessment mission um
they said that they wanted to send
100 long-term observers and 400
short-term observers and i've just
learned pretty recently
that they were unable to recruit those
individuals because of the u.s handling
of coronavirus and
the response to basically other members
of the organization for security and
cooperation europe were unwilling to
send
um the same numbers of short-term
observers that they've been able to send
in the past i think
mainly out of concern for their safety
um and so what we're having
this year in one of the more contentious
elections the us has experienced in
quite some time
um is a limited mission with about 30
long-term observers
under normal circumstances they would
deploy
throughout the country to try to have a
combination of coverage
of a representative snapshot of what's
going on
and to cover places that they think
might be particularly contentious
and that they should be there to try to
see what's going on
and so is it normal that international
observance can cover that wide or
large territory even though there's so
few little of them
is that even reliable so i think a lot
of people emphasize
you know the short-term observers that
are going around from pulling station to
boiling station on election day
that's mostly what i've done is i've
been a short-term observer and spent
a little bit of time in the uh the head
offices in country of election
observation missions
um and the head office is where honestly
a lot of the action is
um they're talking with stakeholders
throughout the country uh they're often
monitoring the media
uh they're meeting with political
parties they're meeting with candidates
um and they're following what's
happening in a more general sense
often they're sitting um or visiting the
election commission
and observing the deployment of
materials so there's a ton
of things that are maybe even more
important that they observe and that
they can't observe from
um with with a smaller group of experts
um and of staff uh that i think it's not
as
it's not very photo it's not a great
photo opportunity so i think
people tend to tend to see that less um
but you're right
um you know for a country as big as the
u.s or
um indonesia where i've also been an
election observer has more
more territory to cover and more more
polling stations to cover than the
united states does
um a few hundred observers um they
they can uncover things right they do
find things and they do document things
but to say they've been comprehensive is
is really difficult and so what they
often do
is coordinate their reporting with
citizen observer groups which are often
able to deploy very widely
in many countries throughout the world
and as long as they're
reputable and nonpartisan they can often
discuss their shared findings and talk
about them so they are at least
having those connections and having more
resources to do
the job which is much better than doing
it themselves i have here another
question
from mateo santoro he says hi from the
uk
hi mateo and western democracy is the
impact of covet 19 has seen the role of
parliamentary
chambers put in second place executive
orders emergency decree
and bills have been approved without the
oversight of the parliamentary bodies
around what type of surveillance
mechanisms they are in place to tackle
this phenomenon
yeah this is exactly what i have been
thinking about in relation to this
this essay and and in in relation to the
broader trend so
um in uh the not too distant past
an important check on overreach
by many governments throughout the world
um or the the abuse of
of power the abusive institutions was
some degree of concern for their own
international reputations
a lot of leaders i think were quite
concerned with how they were perceived
globally
and were watching just to make sure that
they didn't overstep and they weren't
shamed um not just domestically but also
internationally
and this trend that you point to um i
don't have any
um hard data on how frequent that is but
uh just based on your your description
um and your assertion that this has
happened in a number of places i have
also heard anecdotal reports of this
happening
um in a number of places i think it's
reflective of uh the trend that i
mentioned earlier which is leaders
thinking about how to consolidate their
hold on power
um and using this as an opportunity for
their own exercise of power
right i i hope that you know there can
be some mechanisms to
observe that as scholars as yourself and
others to report this
i have another question here from sylvia
can you address the effects of this
instance of democratic backsliding on
tensions and peace between democratic
states
yeah so uh i'm not sure if this uh uh
individual uh sequoia if you're
referencing the democratic piece which
is an important finding
in international relations about the
tendency for democracies
not to go to war with one another so
it's an empirical regularity that's been
documented historically
um we uh
this is a strange thing to say to a
general audience and i hope it comes
across
the right way but as a scholar sometimes
when
bad things happen in the world it
creates an opportunity for us to better
understand
things that we have long been trying to
look for
opportunities to to dig into and so we
don't really know
how democratic backsliding is going to
influence that empirical regularity that
democracies tend to not go to war with
one another
um it's possible that as democracy
erodes
um and as democratic institutions and
systems of public checks and
accountability become hollowed out
at least for some of the theories that
purport to explain the democratic piece
we'd expect
that some of those countries would be
more likely to go to war with one
another
but it hasn't i don't think that we yet
know
um but i'm sure some of my colleagues
are paying attention to that very
closely
yeah thank you for that input suzanne we
have a question here from joseph carys
and
he says could you expand a bit on what
democratic leaders can do to restore the
faith and institutions particularly in
regards to misinformation propaganda
campaigns
so i've been um being i've been asked a
question about what i think is one of
the greatest threats to democracy
these days and i think that
misinformation and the siloing of public
consumption of information such that
partisans of of one party get their
information from one source
partisans of another party get the
information from another source combined
with disinformation and combined with
um the sort of news feeds and the
personalized headlines that many people
are getting
i think that this does become a real
threat to
um to democracy and the reason
i think this question has actually hit
the nail on the head um
it is very hard to rebuild trust if
there's no way to communicate to voters
across the political spectrum
so for for a democratic leader who is
interested in rebuilding trust in
institutions
um in combating misinformation they
would have to find a way to break
through those informational silos
um and break through the algorithms that
are sorting people into like-minded um
pockets of people and and to encourage
them to
um think about um maybe uh what it means
to be a citizen of that country what
their
what their rights are um how uh what
democracy means is really
um being willing to take it to take time
losing right take a turn
at sitting out of power uh on the
promise that you'll be able to come back
into power someday soon
so then would because these
misinformation happening in social media
is just through all my platforms would
you say that maybe leaders have to
look for ways to promote these type of
conversations offline
having those person to person or going
through different cities to perhaps
combat that you know i think the
solution
uh is not yet clear to me i'm not sure
that the solution is all about going
offline
uh we're obviously all living most of
our work lives online now
um it's very hard to get uh completely
away from social media
um i do think that um
there's room for uh for national leaders
of many countries around the world to do
more to try to
teach their citizens how to think about
what
um what high quality information
is and when what it looks like and who
they should trust um but
that's so corruptible right i mean how
do we trust those leaders to do that
that correctly so i think exactly
that point brings me to another question
from kenny and hopefully
i'm pronouncing that correctly but he
says how has democratic processes been
affected and compromised by money
so is this probably another threat to
democracy
oh gosh um uh it's very hard to hold
elections with
zero money right just running an
election um without any campaigning
um still costs money it has to come from
somewhere right
um and again we're talking about
elections amongst large numbers of
people
as some of the old school theorists of
democracy would emphasize
you can you can do it on the cheap if
you don't have that many people but
clearly money in politics is corrupting
and it's not clear exactly what the
solution to that might be
so i'll just say yes it can corrupt the
process
um it's been a problem for many
countries around the world
uh there are some things like public
financing of campaigns
that some people think are are useful
things to implement to try to help deal
with money in politics
um but for the most part the the central
problem
is not just about um candidates coming
with money to racists but also about
um political parties who are in power
using the apparatus of the state uh to
generate support for their own candidacy
right a sort of abuse of state resources
to try to keep them in power
that's also a very big problem and even
if you have lots of rules against
um campaign contributions or that kind
of thing you'll still have that
potential problem
of parties and candidates who are in
power having the temptation to try to
abuse state resources to stay
definitely not a very straight answer or
solution
for sure there's many nuances to it
which brings me now to my next question
from matthew ray
and he asked can you comment on the
effects that the policies and practices
of social media companies have had on
democracies
around the world oh that's a little bit
out of my depth i don't want to get
myself in trouble
i'm certainly not an expert in the
variation in uh social media company
policies around the world
i will say that one of the things i do
reference in my piece is that
some authoritarian governments are still
very much
worried about the spread of information
and i don't mean disinformation i mean
accurate information about what they're
doing and have engaged in things like
internet filtering and the selective
censorship
of content for example about protests
against other governments in the region
and this is something that that other
scholars have documented it's a really
interesting trend
um i do i will say just very briefly
that i think that social media companies
could do more
um to be socially responsible and to not
to
to do less to undermine democrats in the
world
well bringing it back to you actually uh
to your expertise and the review is that
what can citizens of democracies can do
to engage with this problem of
democratic backsliding
yeah that's a great question so one of
the i'll say two things very quickly one
is that many people interpret this
through a partisan lens and i think it's
important to emphasize that you can
support democracy
separately from your own political views
um this in many countries shouldn't be
a a partisan issue um
and uh what citizens can do i think is
think about
how their actions are both
interpreted as defending democracy in
their country if that's something
they're interested in doing
and something that can be partisan so
there's a range of actions that citizens
can take
to try to support democracy i have to
say that
globally around the world sometimes that
means accepting loss
in an election uh peacefully that's what
democracy is based on and everybody does
have to take
um a time um take a turn sitting
um losing an election and it's
unpleasant right it's unpleasant for
everyone who's ever experienced that i
think around the world
but it's unpleasant when you fear
that the party in power is going to take
away democracy and this will be your
last opportunity to fight for it so i
just encourage the separation of those
two things
yeah thank you for clarifying the
differences between the two we have
a question from marco pom and he asked
how has political advertisement on the
internet with the help of
micro targeting influence elections
that's an interesting question so
there's a version of it that's very
benign
and micro targeting is just more
efficient for political campaigns to
speak to voters about issues they care
about
um if i look at that from the
perspective of
my interest in election manipulation and
election fraud
it's very hard to see in micro targeting
to see disinformation and who the
disinformation might be affecting
in real time such that you can do
something to
defend against that type of
disinformation so for example
a common voter suppression tactic it's
not new
um but bringing micro targeting into it
makes it i think more pernicious which
is
uh when people are told that their no
their polling station has moved when it
has not in fact moved or that their
method of voting that they were planning
to use is no longer a
method of voting that's allowed when
that information is false
it's called voter suppression and it can
be ver it can be much harder to document
that it's happening
call it out and do something about it if
the micro targeting makes it harder to
sort of see all of the ways in which
that disinformation is being
sent out to individual citizens so then
why are all these steps for democracy
backsliding
have been either gradual or are hard to
detect like you're saying what are those
factors
is it because there's no real time to
document that even if
the same voters when they go to the
polls they can record with their phones
and see that they're being suppressed or
places are being shut down yeah
so the so it's very tricky right there
there's cases all around the world of um
disinformation about election
manipulation too right so sometimes
people
um will try to accuse um the other side
of manipulation when they feel like
they're when they feel like they're
losing
and they might just be losing right this
is a very common tactic for losers
or candidates who are losing so um some
people think that the sort of
crowdsourcing
of election protection and the ability
of citizens to record problems with
elections
is going to be a big deterrent um i
think it's possible that that can help
in some cases
i think it's important to note that
there's there's two things going on
there one is that
um if it's just self-reported uh we may
be missing some of the most important
places in which election manipulation is
happening
without a systematic systematic effort
to document it
and if if there's a number of other
things going on as well
it could just be hard to know when some
of those videos are manipulated right
we're getting into the world of deep
fakes we're getting into
technological innovation in which lots
of people can come up with
uh really strange but sometimes
effective ways to try to make their
political opponents look bad and
sometimes that's by
falsifying charges of election
manipulation or
confusing the irregularities that happen
in any election that are not
that are not necessarily a partisan
trying to sort of cast those as as
partisan yeah well i definitely admire
the work that the international election
observance do because
it's definitely uh tricky and we
are getting closer to the end of our
facebook live
uh and i just i would like to squeeze in
one more question as if possible and
his his name is michael erdermann and he
asked when might the level of non-voters
factor into a democracy
so i am a person who thinks that
non-participation
it can be a democratic act for a voter
so some countries have compulsory voting
um then i think it's fine for citizens
to spoil their ballots there's a good
way for
um it's it's part of democracy for
citizens to be able to communicate their
dissatisfaction with all of the options
um and that that's one way to do it um i
do think that
um what we often see is that young
people
um and certain groups within a society
um choose not to participate because
um they don't um feel as though the
process is working for them or something
like that
um and i do think that at least from my
perspective
political participation across all
sectors of society is important
so ranging from young people to old
people but also different demographic
groups
that's an important thing for a country
to have if it is calling itself a
democracy
and so when a lot of people disengage
from the process it gives those who stay
more power um and so that that in itself
is i think a really
uh important thing to acknowledge when
people are turning away from the process
um of course there's something called
election boycotts where parties say this
process is so bad
that our party is refusing to
participate and those can also be very
powerful at
delegitimizing an electoral process when
it's deserved
so so far we've learned what's the role
of an international
observant for elections is about
democracy processes through electing
and even voting or not voting
and as well the different tactics that
many governments might use
through elections to continue to stay in
power
so before we leave this discussion do
you have
anything else that you would like to add
susan especially
uh how the feedback has been uh on your
publication perhaps
yeah i think that um it's been just a
delight and an honor to engage with
people from uh
you know outside of my own field and
outside of political science
about this topic i do think that
there's a lot of changes in the
international system including
including increasing power of russia and
china um
the us turning away from what has been a
global leadership role that has often
been problematic but has been
generally pro-democracy um these things
are
are important global shifts and they
have repercussions in many countries
throughout the world and so
i'm not trying to say that um one is bad
and the other is good
far from it i just think that they're
consequential changes and it will be
interesting to see
uh how they play out in the coming years
well we look forward to your thoughts as
well as all of these things continue to
move
i would like to thank everyone for
joining us today
my name is val from the science magazine
media office team
and you can find susan's latest review
in this post i just clicked on the link
and you can see
further thoughts on susan's about the
democratic backsliding
so thank you everyone so much again
thank you val thank you thank you susan